lo que haremos en este vídeo es
refrescar nuestro entendimiento del
valor posicional pero trataremos de
profundizar un poco más pensando en el
valor posicional dentro del contexto de
los decimales recordemos un poco si
tengo el número 973 esto será un repaso
para ustedes ya sabemos que este espacio
corresponde a las unidades unidades y
después una posición a la izquierda
tenemos a las decenas observen que al
pasar de las unidades a las escenas
estas son diez veces más que las
unidades y si nos movemos otra posición
hacia la izquierda nuevamente
multiplicamos por diez y ahora nos
encontramos en las centenas por lo tanto
este 9 no es solamente un 9 sino que
representa 9 zenten es que lo podemos
escribir como 900 e igualmente este 7 no
es solamente un 7 porque representa
siete decenas es decir siete
y como este 3 representa tres unidades
solo es son tres pero como les prometí
vamos a ampliar nuestro conocimiento
porque voy a poner un punto decimal aquí
a la derecha probablemente ya lo han
visto antes y la razón por la que
necesitamos un punto decimal es porque
nos dice claramente cuál es la posición
de las unidades
entonces si nos movemos una posición
desde la derecha hacia la izquierda del
punto decimal esta es la posición de la
unidad y cuando empezamos a usar
decimales podemos poner tantos espacios
como queramos hacia la derecha del punto
decimal
pensemos un poco más en eso vamos a ver
observen que cuando nos movemos de
centenas a decenas dividimos entre 10 y
cuando pasamos de decenas a unidades
nuevamente dividimos entre 10 por lo
tanto como creen que se le llama a esta
posición que pasa cuando dividimos 1
entre 10 claro nos queda un décimo así
que como ya se imaginaron esta es la
posición de las décimas
y después si nos movemos otra posición
hacia la derecha cuál será esta posición
bueno ahora dividimos un décimo entre 10
o dicho de otra manera es una décima
parte de un décimo entonces aquí tenemos
la posición de las centésimas
centésimas y así cada vez más podemos
seguirnos moviendo una posición hacia la
derecha para siempre pero si por ahora
solo nos movemos a la derecha una
posición más que tenemos bueno ahora es
una décima dividida entre 100 o dicho de
otra manera una décima parte de una
centésima que corresponde a las
milésimas esta es la posición de las
milésimas entonces por ejemplo si en
lugar de sólo escribir 973 escribimos
novecientos setenta y 3.526 que es lo
que representan estos dígitos
bueno este 5 no es solamente un 5 sino
que representa cinco décimas otra forma
de escribir cinco décimas es 0.5
simplemente colocamos un 5 en la
posición de las décimas o también lo
podemos escribir como cinco décimos
bien ahora este 2 bueno yo creo que ya
saben a dónde vamos este no es solamente
un 2 sino que en este caso representa
dos centésimas entonces son dos
centésimas y otra forma de escribirlo es
simplemente escribiendo el número dos en
la posición de las centésimas porque nos
movemos 12 espacios hacia la derecha del
punto decimal o también lo podemos
escribir como 2 entre 100 2 centésimos y
bueno como un reto pausa en el vídeo y
tratan de descubrir cuáles son las
diferentes formas en las que se puede
representar este 6 que es lo que
representa este 6 claro corresponde a
seis milésimas seis milésimas que
también los podemos escribir como cero
punto aquí sería la posición de las
décimas centésimas y aquí en la posición
de las milésimas ponemos el 6 o también
lo podemos escribir como 6 entre 1000
y 6 milésimas así que a grandes rasgos
podemos continuar el valor posicional
hacia la derecha del punto decimal las
veces que queramos y así podemos
representar números más precisos